what we're going to do in this video is
talk more about inflation and deflation
which we've talked about in other videos
but we're going to talk about it in the
context of who benefits and who gets
hurt especially in a situation where
people are lending money to each other
at fixed rates
so let's set up a little scenario here
so let's say that this is today
and this is in one year so in
one
year
and today i need my teeth cleaned it's
an emergency but i don't have money to
clean my teeth it costs a hundred
dollars and you're my okay friend and
you say yes you do need your teeth
cleaned i will lend you a hundred
dollars but i want to charge some
interest
so today from my point of view i am
going to borrow
i am going to borrow
100 from you my okay friend and in a
year i have to pay back you're gonna
charge me 10 interest so i'm going to
have to pay back
pay back
now let's think about some different
scenarios on inflation
so let's imagine a world where there's
no inflation so let's say in let's say
today is my base period where the cpi is
100 and let's imagine that the actual
basket of goods in our country is
actually a hundred dollars it'll help us
visualize things a little bit more and
let's say we have no inflation so in one
year the cpi that basket of goods is
still
so in real terms and in future videos
we'll talk more about real and nominal
terms
but in real terms you could buy 10
more with 110 than you could with that
hundred dollars so you really got a real
return but now let's imagine a scenario
with a little bit of inflation a
reasonable amount where
in our base year our cpi is 100 and then
in a year maybe we've had two percent
inflation so now our consumer price
index is 102.
well in this scenario you're now and
especially if we view that basket of
goods as actually costing a hundred
dollars in the first year and then 102
one year later as we've talked about
that's not always going to be the case
in fact in most countries it's not that
you can actually buy that basket of
goods for a hundred dollars the hundred
is usually just to be indicative but
this is to be to help us make things a
little bit more tangible in this world
you're going to buy be able to buy more
than a basket of goods but not 10 more
you're going to be able to buy a little
bit less than 8 percent more
and then we can set up a scenario where
we have fairly extreme inflation and
this will make things very clear where
our cpi goes from 100 to let's say that
price is
more than double so let's say we go to a
world where our cpi so this would be
pretty pretty extreme inflation where
our cpi goes to 220.
so this is really interesting because
in
right now at the present what you are
lending me that's equivalent to the
basket of goods i could actually buy the
basket of goods there while in year one
what i'm paying back to you you can only
buy half a basket of goods and so you
lent me money and even though nominally
it looks just superficially like you're
getting 10 more in terms of dollars you
can buy half as much with that 110
dollars as you could have bought a year
ago with that hundred dollars so in this
world even though it looks like you're
getting a 10
nominal return your real return is
pretty bad your real return is negative
you can buy half as much with what
you're getting paid back as what you
originally lent
and so the general trend here
is when you are in an inflationary
environment especially when the
inflation is more than expected
oftentimes the interest rate will bake
in some inflation people will expect
some inflation in the interest rate but
in general inflation is going to the
more inflation you have and think about
it from my point of view i borrowed
something where i could have bought the
basket of goods if you imagine the
basket of goods actually costs a hundred
dollars and i'm paying back something
where that would only buy half a basket
of goods you could even imagine with
that hundred dollars i buy a basket of
goods and then a year later i sell that
basket of goods for 220 and then i only
have to pay half of that 220 back to you
and so i and i would have gotten my
teeth cleaned in that situation
but i would have been able to profit
from that thing and so inflation
especially when it's more than expected
inflation it benefits borrowers at fixed
rates benefits
borrowers
at fixed rates and i keep saying at
fixed rates because it's possible that
your interest rate might somehow be
pegged to inflation which case it might
not benefit you so much and it hurts
lenders
it hurts
at fixed rates
now as you can imagine deflation is
going to be the opposite and to make
this very clear i'll make a very extreme
deflationary scenario imagine we go from
a cpi of
100 to a cpi
cpi of 55 and if we literally view our
that same basket of goods that would
have cost 100
only cost 55 now think about it i am
borrowing equivalent of a basket of
goods and that i'm paying back to you
two baskets of goods 110 would buy two
baskets of goods in a year and so in
this deflationary scenario in this
deflationary
scenario
you are actually getting even though
nominally it looks like you're getting a
10 return the lender is getting a 10
return the real return they're getting a
hundred percent return they're able to
buy twice as much with what they get
back than what what they lent and so
this deflation hurts borrowers at fixed
rates hurts
borrowers
at fixed rates and it helps and it helps
lenders
lenders at fixed rates